tonight I did sense a little bit of
chemistry still between you and Nick I
thank and you said that you think he
misses you what was it like seeing him
um it was it was hard you know um to
watch the video playback and then to see
him at the same time it brought back a
lot of emotions it was bittersweet is
what I say it was so good to see him but
at the same time it was hard because
watching the video back and seeing how I
left and it brought back all that
emotion even though it had been a few
months since it happened but at the end
of the day it was great to see him still
any feelings there I mean no not not in
that sense like it may be like I miss
him just because we really do have like
a good chemistry and a good friendship
and I miss that aspect of it but it I
mean I'm happy for him and in everything
that he's doing alright your first tell
all who was it hardest to see here
tonight I think like Rachel mentioned
how when you watch things back you you
you go ahead and go back to that place
so you know I have no regrets all the
women were great throughout the
throughout the journey or the process
rather I don't know if they were hard to
see it was nice to see that you know for
me you know I again I don't have regrets
about my decision I always felt good
about it and so as nervous as I was it
was very nice to see all of them how was
it seeing Rachel here tonight you guys
still seem to have a really good
connection and a good relationship to
each other right to see Rachel like I'm
so excited for her
I felt like Rachel I became not only
romantically involved while we dated but
fast friends and great friends and as a
friend I miss her
you know and I wish her well and maybe
down the line we'll be able to rekindle
that friendship but I'm very excited for
her her journey I think she's gonna be
great and I can't wait to see if she
finds the love and happiness
[Music]
you